On January 1st Colorado became the first
state in the world to allow legal
marijuana sales to anybody over 21 for
recreational use that's right
not just for medical use any
recreational use Colorado residents are
able to possess an ounce of marijuana
nan Colorado residents a quarter ounce
but who are we kidding that's still a
ton of weed just in the first day
Colorado marijuana sales made well over
1 million dollar 2014 will see a 571
million dollar profit on legal marijuana
sales the taxes are estimated to bring
67 million per year initially 27.5 will
go to school construction and six
million will go to local governments
that leaves 30 3.5 million for the state
to regulate stores and fund marijuana
education and treatment programs apps
tourism and marijuana merchandise expect
to get a boost as well creating jobs and
growing the economy yeah cuz that stuff
wasn't being made before studies predict
that more than fourteen states will
legalize marijuana within the next five
years creating a potential ten point two
billion dollar cannabis market by 2018
although about half the population force
since nineteen sixty has tried the drug
and we have over 3.6 million daily users
more per capita than any other country
seven hundred forty nine thousand eight
hundred twenty-five arrests were made in
2012 for violation of marijuana laws but
no prior offenders will be left off the
hook of course there are concerns and
restrictions getting high in public is
still prohibited driving while stud will
remain strictly illegal in Colorado
other opponents expect that it may
affect the culture many adults fear in a
culture with no legal repercussions
teens will be more apt to smoke the drug
without the paralyzing paranoia their
parents underwent in the 1970s basement
they argue that it will result in a
culture of laziness and choosing to
chase of marijuana high instead of
pursuits like arts and literature only
time will tell how these new laws will
affect the song what do you think will
happen